so how did you make the move from sort
of hollywood hollywood
to conservative hollywood yeah it's not
quite the same thing as we have
found out multiple times well no
hollywood hollywood pays conservative
hollywood
does not check true during the george w
bush administration
with that group of men who who i was
getting the opportunity to kind of come
of age with
uh because i had this sort of pastoral
role
in the community you know i also engaged
with
with the guys on world view on broader
world view and i would always sort of be
arguing the conservative points of view
i had become a conservative because uh i
went to college for two years you know
i'm very anti-college
but i went to college for two years at a
at a junior college in loveland texas
that has a commercial music program they
literally teach you how to play
bluegrass so they teach how to play
and a bunch of country stars have gone
through there again natalie mains of the
dixie chicks leanne womack
several others over the years and while
i was there i had this professor who
was ostensibly supposed to teach me how
to play the piano
if you've ever heard me play the piano
you know that he failed mightily at his
job
but i had this private lesson with him
twice a week and we would argue about
politics and religion
and he was very libertarian he would
hand out copies of
these books by uh richard mayberry
called
whatever happened to penny candy and
whatever happened to justice
which are sort of easy libertarian
tracts you know and
um i disagreed with almost all of his
philosophy and i would argue with him
and i i never realized that he was
winning the arguments
until i got a couple years down the road
got to la and realized that i was taking
his position
instead of the position that i had
formerly had and so
you know in that way he really helped me
discover my beliefs
and now i was trying to help these guys
you know refine some of their beliefs
and as a result everyone knew that i was
very conservative you know one of my
buddies at that time was on a sitcom on
abc
which was great because the rest of us
were dirt poor and you could go over
there and eat for free you know craft
service on a film set or a tv set is
amazing there's just
constant food and catered meals so i
would go over and we'd play halo up in
this dressing room
and then i would like hide water bottles
in my pocket
and i had a bush cheney 2004 bumper
sticker at that time on my truck
and i would park right behind his sort
of supercar on the lot
and one day i'm walking up the stairs
you know with like i mean peanuts and
bottled water a turkey leg
all hidden under my coat and this
wonderful actress you know who i had
grown up watching on a show with my
father and was really
kind of starstruck and probably love
truck by
sees me coming up the stairs and she
says hey uh
real quick is that your pickup that
parks right behind and i said yeah yeah
she was
you're aware that there's a bush cheney
bumper sticker on the back of your truck
oh yeah yeah it's i put it there just oh
you got balls of steel kid
and until she said it i honestly didn't
know i was too naive
to know that you just can't do that in
this town
and sort of like when you learn a new
word you hear the new word everywhere
i started hearing all the bias now all
around me all the time
how political is a film set how
political is a television set
how the number one topic of conversation
on film and television sets
is politics and that may sound obvious
now because
in the in the trump era everything is so
political
it but the world had not yet become
political only hollywood was political
like this at the time
and i realized pretty early on that
that was going to create problems for me
because i
am just too ornery and probably too
stupid to
play along you know i've i've got that
texas streak in me where i
i say what i think and you know damn the
torpedoes kind of a thing
if you enjoyed this video be sure to hit
the thumbs up button and share it with
all of your friends